Tụi từ Instagram Benjamin nên tà dấu hương ngày bể tạm thăm em một kêu gọi các nước trong khu vực
cùng Instagram loại bỏ hàn toàn được lượng hà mắt và như là giữa ổ hộ nhóm này khỏi chung đồng.
Ông nói lập trường Instagram là không chứm nhật bất kỳ vài chọn từng loại nào
của lượng hà mắt tại giải gà dà nó dương và trong cọng đồng về Pestine ở trong
trên bố được lưu ra chỉ một ngày sau khi hội đồng bảo ân lihe hấp quốc thông quang nghĩ quế
ông hộ kể hoạt hai medium của thông thông nghĩ tôi nên trăm nhằm chấm dẫn rào trang and bảo tại thiết giải gà dà.
Kể hoạt gồm quân khổn và bắn cơ chơi chào đội con tín và một dài đoạn trình tiếp
gió hỏi đồng hòa bình giám sát để thu phố kinh tế.
Bắn kể đồng thời cho các chình thay lực lượng quốc tế để phòng định giải gà dà và yêu cầu phía quân sự hóa
khu vực trong đó thu hội phụ khí và phá huy hạ tần quân sự.
Tuy nhiên, kể hoạt thông yêu cầu trục xuất bắt bộ được lượng hà mắt, mà chỉ quy định những thành viên chấm nhận giải giới
sẽ được ít giả và có thể giới gà dà ăn toàn.
Phà đừng với gị quết, hà mắt nói sẽ không giải giá và cho giang câu chơi mới áp đặt sự giảm hộ của tế lên giải gà dà.
Nhọn của cạnh báo, lượng của tế sẽ mất tình chung lập, nhiều tìm cách tức vụ khí của họ.
Chào khi đó, hình quyết, phải là steam khi hóa nghe nhỉ quết và sẵn giáng tham gia thích thích.
Một số trình ra nhìn đệnh lập trường đủ lập, giới isceran và hà mắt khiến tiến trình thực hiện kể hoạt của Mỹ đổi mặt nhiều thách thật.